good evening thank you thank you good
evening and welcome to a very special
episode of late night tonight's program
begins with a story before every show I
come out and I talk to the audience
get to know them and most importantly
implore them to laugh it's tradition
well about a year ago I began to notice
that every night there were two or three
people from Finland in the crowd much to
my surprise I learned our show airs in
Finland and does quite well over there
then one night one of our finished fans
in the audience brought me a photo and
pointed out that I looked just like the
president of Finland Tarija Hallinan
[Applause]
well then things got a lot more
interesting president Halonen you see it
was in the middle of a close reelection
campaign and I decided to help I I
didn't know anything about her politics
I just enjoy looking like the president
of a country even if it's a woman so we
made silly campaign ads in Finnish
supporting her which aired in Finland as
a result president Halonen was handily
re-elected in a stunning three percent
landslide well the next step for me was
clear I had to go to Finland and see
this country whose fate had mysteriously
become entwined with my own tonight for
a full hour you will join me as I travel
through this amazing land and meet the
great and noble people of Finland our
adventure begins as my plane lands in
the capital the city of Helsinki I had
no idea what to expect and it was a day
I will not soon forget
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much for welcoming me
this way if you don't mind I'd like to
read a brief statement in your own
language hey Suleiman Khan sir Cato seta
Olin terrible tulips on your Cowen Anton
oops oh thank you yes ladies chance I'm
interested in a cabinet position I'd
like to be the inspector of saunas
occasionally male saunas it's the man's
good looking and his well varies from
person to person of course but then you
describe yourself as a you know reserved
finished person or kind of a crazy
finished person well on weekends yeah
I'm a bit crazy yes what's your craziest
hmm I like to run for offices that I
can't reach like the Bank of Finland and
the European Parliament I've run them
all these posts but I never have had any
success so you have too much to drink
you run for public office
[Applause]
your hard time would you ever say man
would you ever do that so that's all
human of course can we hear you do that
give you a hard time
hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy
hey buddy come on my god stop that me my
madman
so that was a crazy minister Conan
O'Brien in hotel in eraser parent mm5
assessed our master li kui Eliyahu you
told Anna Costa Adeje said Tanya donelly
a Latin epic avocado yatta hakuna to
talk policies womanizing you watch my
show yeah we excited that I was coming
to Finland when you find out do you more
what Walker Texas Walker Texas Ranger
Pet Shop Boys do you think you like the
pet shop boys think they they're dead
aren't they do you like Pet Shop Boys
and you like Late Night with Conan
O'Brien okay wow that makes me feel like
my shows right on the cutting edge you
guys wanted me in here I am oh yeah oh
I'm sorry I thought your food Finland
Oh cuz it's me it's Conan O'Brien do
know this is essential harbor too much
the water is frozen over one of the
advantages is that if you miss your
cruise you can walk after it swap
quickly you should catch the boat within
10-15 minutes and the lecture back on
anything yes that's me
wait come aboard Bible this meant a I'm
just randomly invited on boats
ah nice convenient look at this right
here look at that that's an ominous
diagram right there is that something
that happens daily here does that see
you know what a sinking boat looks like
we can tell the fins are a hard-drinking
people this is just a tugboat and it
needs one two three reminders not to
drink martinis
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Avery he's a doctor from the
United States you're visiting in the
conference yes I am
just just a fun cruise for you right now
it's pretty much just lights a right
sight scene I haven't seen a living
thing I mean they're there I don't see
any wildlife at all just rumor that
there was a polar bear I'm one of those
Islands over there pretty shot himself
what kind of doctor are you
dermatologist okay can you see there
it's okay stop it stop look at okay see
we listen I do it your way
this is the Sonos era which is finished
for sauna society it's a place where
people can have a sauna they can come
here relax and reenact the climax from
Fargo
[Applause]
[Music]
Sekulow set buh-buh-buh say that again
please please say it again oh no you
don't finish oh yes one great many
languages I've forgotten it already now
Charles is Charles right
concept is you go into a room
superheated you get the body very very
very very very very hot right and you
run outside yeah and can you jump in
extremely cold water yeah this is the
Baltic Sea yes actually it's the sea you
know you know I realize it's a sea
because it's frozen right no put it in
salt water it's saltwater but normally
this time of the year like February we
have so cold at the evenly the saltwater
freezes look at that that's incredible
you know you're in Finland when someone
says gonna go I'm gonna go take my dog
out I'll take Rover out for a walk on
the frozen Baltic Sea way way out there
we got here several hours ago and he was
in the exact same position just sitting
there
yeah it's barely cold out here is there
any chance he's dead a lot of people
just died and slump over on the subway
all the time so this is actually where
the with the dunking takes place the
immersion and they walk down these
stairs and they just keep on walking
until you know water a water level up
here if you stop in the middle you come
back because it's it it's freezing cold
you know
there's only in the water you must be
naked is that the costume you can do it
and the baby so good is what's there to
hide another buddies like you want to
hide your pants yeah
woody if you go in the water like this
it will be it will be so little on color
okay
[Applause]
can you have a group photo with you I
won't get pageant dress for tune yeah
yeah and after after the sauna you take
a sausage something to eat something
salty because you lose your buddy
minerals here in yes bro so I find out
after I've been hanging around a lot of
naked then the first thing I want to do
is bite into a sausage chewing some
sausage and then afterwards the sausage
yes there's something I've noticed felt
it out too much but the point is you
have this custom and God bless you
that's what I say
more power to you
[Music]
[Applause]